Jordan McSweeney is 29 years old
and has 28 previous convictions for 69
crimes dating back to 2006.
they range from racially motivated
offenses driving offenses and an assault
on police
to battery and assault occasioning
actual bodily harm
he began his criminal career as a
teenager which may be a sign of the
dysfunctional family experience he had
endured
nothing he was deprived of in terms of
familial love
boundaries
safety or security could begin to
justify his actions and attitudes as an
independent adult with the ability to
reason and opportunities to reform
available to him
on the 17th of June 2022 he was released
from custody
after serving a portion of a custodial
sentence
on the 21st of June he went to live with
a friend in his Caravan
in a fun fair in Valentine Park ilford
as part of his release on license he was
supposed to attend appointments with the
probation service but he failed to do
that
breach of this condition would as he
would have been told lead to his arrest
and return to detention
his license was revoked on the 24th of
June
on the night of the 26th of June just
nine days after release from prison
Jordan McSweeney was prowling the
streets of ilford looking for a woman to
attack
his victim that night was Zara Alina a
smart and successful 35 year old a
complete stranger
someone whose values and character were
entirely the opposite of his
she had studied law
and was due to be admitted onto the
solicitors role
miscellaneous Aunt foreigners and her
grandmother rushed a Parveen have told
the court in articulate elegant and
moving terms how precious and special
the woman this defendant sexually
assaulted and murdered was
every human being has her own essential
qualities
Zara believed in Justice she had a
strong moral compass she filled her life
with Big Ideas big plans and a zest for
existence
she was confident
and active working and volunteering to
use her talents to the full
she was well loved her mother's only
child
and her death has broken that woman
Zara's absence is being felt constantly
by the entire family
the extended family
the light has gone out from their lives
they have told the court
they will campaign for a better world in
her name for the life she lost having
done nothing wrong they want to make the
world safer for others
the defendant had been drinking that
night with the friend whose Caravan he
was sharing
he was pestering women he groped a woman
at the great spoon of ilford and tried
to molest a female member of staff
eventually he was ejected just after 11
pm
he walked off in the direction of Crumb
book Road and for the next two hours
proud around desperate to find a victim
he was captured just after midnight
obviously intoxicated and following a
woman a stranger down Romford Road
he deployed some degree of subterfuge
waiting to get her in front and falling
behind when she appeared to notice him
the woman May well have realized he was
following her because wisely she entered
a shop and showed her wariness by
looking backwards towards the doorway
indeed he hung around outside that shop
waiting for her to leave he entered and
left without making any purchase
she watched him leave and waited yet
more time before leaving herself
he was still in the vicinity but hidden
and she waited for a while in the
cartilage of the shop
when she moved away the defendant
emerged and followed her down Gloucester
Road she began to run and she outrun him
it is no hyperbole to say that her
actions that night saved her life
this Pursuit had lasted 21 minutes that
woman has not been identified
before long the defendant saw another
potential victim who was inside a
chicken shop on Romford Road
he entered and stared at her and put his
spoke to the defendant he put his arm
around her and his hand between her legs
before desisting
the two of them walks down a side street
and paused together but she then walked
away it is not known whether this was
another encounter with a stranger or the
defendant knew her he has not said
for the next 50 minutes he remained
wandering around in Cranbrook Road
despite being minutes from where he was
living
shortly before 2 A.M he came across a
fourth woman who came out of a side road
into Cranbrook Road
the defendant's attention turned to her
immediately and he followed her into
Northbrook Road and Beyond over the
course of minutes
this was in my judgment another
deliberate Pursuit
and her actions on the CCTV looking back
over her shoulder and speeding up her
walk indicate that she also became aware
of it
he overtook her and turned into one of
the houses in the street obviously
waiting to surprise and grab her
he was disappointed because she happened
to be making her way to a house on the
opposite side of the street and was able
to enter it safely
coincidentally Zara Alina and her friend
bamini bati had been in the great spoon
of ilford II earlier in the evening
but by 2 am they were leaving a bar
called Champs Sports Bar in Chapel Road
nearby
Miss Elena decided to walk home she did
not have far to go
her friend Miss batty had called a taxi
as many women do these days she called
her friend to check that Zara had got
home safely but she never got any
response
the defendant and Miss Alina reached the
junction of Northbrook and Cranbrook
roads at the same time
it was a fatal coincidence
he waited for her to go past and then
cross the road so that he was behind her
he followed her for some distance
getting to within a few meters of her
until she reached number 268 a
residential property on Cranbrook Road
with a wide paved front garden or
driveway
at that point there were no other people
on the street
the attack was captured on domestic
security cameras
he grabbed her and pulled her backwards
one arm around her neck the other over
her mouth
she was dragged deeper into the darkness
of the driveway and it's clear that she
struggled and fought him
but he had the advantage of surprise and
strength and he was successful in
subduing her
he then parted her legs while she was on
the ground but still she fought and
resisted getting up again
he attacked her and pulled her back onto
the ground she must have been rendered
unconscious because he then dragged her
around without independent movement from
her
he removed some of her clothing and
sexually assaulted her
the security camera on the front of the
house does not provide a clear image of
these events
he kicked and stamped on her his
movements indicating that these were
repeated heavy assaults
he was not carried away he had not been
overtaken by an uncontrollable urge
it's clear that he was wholly aware of
what he was doing
this is indisfutably correct because
when he realized that someone was coming
past the house on the pavement he bent
out of sight before resuming what he was
doing
after satisfying his lust he proceeded
to destroy the woman he had just
degraded with sickening deliberation he
stamped on her
then he left the driveway
but after walking a few meters he
returned
and repeatedly stamped down on her body
again
using the balustrad for balance
he searched her body again and left for
a second time carrying things of hers
still not finished having walked away
this time further he again returned to
miss Selena
and bent down by her body before
stamping on her again
this abduction sexual assault and murder
lasted just nine minutes
he had carried away her phone Keys purse
leggings and underwear and they were
found abandoned
nearby
he was captured on CCTV at the fair
where the Caravan was located with blood
stains on his clothing and trainers as
he returned
Zara Alina's body was found by two
couples walking past an emergency
services were called
some of those members of the public have
been traumatized by what they saw the
court commends their Swift and
compassionate actions in seeking help
Miss Alina was desperately injured
struggling for breath and her life was
in danger
all that could be done was done by the
medical professionals who answered the
999 call
they tried to save her life on the
driveway for over an hour
she arrived at the Royal London Hospital
after 4am and the work continued but by
9 58 am she was dead
she had suffered 46 separate injuries
these included severe blunt force trauma
to her head
deep lacerations to her scalp bruising
to her lips ear eyes nose and jaw
she had suffered genital injuries
the severity of the violence
caused
traumatic brain injury
she died because of the brain injuries
and prolonged neck compression
she had been stamped and strangled to
death
the defendant had left two fingerprints
in Blood on the balustrade
through intelligent and Swift work by
the Metropolitan Police he was quickly
identified and arrested on the 27th of
June at his Caravan in Valentine Park
he made no coherent response to arrest
his blood-stained trainers and genes
were found secreted in the Caravan Park
he had hidden them there in the
afternoon of the 26th of June
his demeanor on the relevant CCTV
footage from the site that afternoon
suggests no cares no regrets no
contrition
at the police station he said he was on
medication for ADHD and suffered from a
split personality disorder
he also claimed to have been bitten by a
dog
he refused treatment and threatened
officers at the station
he made no comment in three police
interviews and exhibited utter
disrespect for the situation he was in
given what he knew he had done so
recently
nothing a judge says can make any
difference to what happened to Miss
Sarah Alina no sentence of the Court can
bring her back
the defendant had the physical
advantages of strength and surprise in
everything else she was better than him
she was talented spirited intelligent
and kind
spending the evening with her friend she
had done nothing wrong taken no misstep
shown No Lack of sense
she was simply a happy healthy woman
living her life in what most londoners
think of as the best city in the world
the defendant has been brought to court
today but has refused to come up to this
courtroom
he has given an excuse that he doesn't
want to revisit the events he is
responsible for
it's agreed that his non-attendance is
voluntary and it is appropriate to
sentence him in his absence
but the defender's decision not to come
up to from the cells to court to hear
the devastating impact of his crimes
shows that the man who took Zara Alina's
life has no spine whatsoever
murder carries a life sentence I have to
determine the minimum term to be served
in accordance with paragraph three of
schedule 21 of the sentencing act 2020
it should be clear to everyone that this
figure is just the minimum and it will
only be when the parole board considers
the defendant is no longer a risk that
he can be released that day may never
come
the prosecution submits that this is a
case in which the seriousness of the
murder considered together with the
sexual assault is particularly High the
defense agree
the starting point for the course
determination both sides agree is
therefore one of 30 years
Mr Glasgow King's Council submits that
accounting for the aggravating and
mitigating features and for the guilty
pleas this case merits a sentence well
in excess of the minimum term
Mr Carter Stevenson King's Council
disagrees and urges the court to pass a
more moderate minimum term in all the
circumstances
in this respect the specific disputes I
have to resolve are fourfold firstly
the prosecution and defense agree that
the evidence is the defendant was
planning to commit a sexual offense and
there is no sign of significant planning
or premeditation for murder
however
I do not agree that this is a case of
someone seeking what has been described
as an intimate encounter
that is far too neutral a term
albeit understandable
most of the defendant's behavior in the
two hours before he dragged Zara Alina
off the street reveals a resolve to find
and attack a vulnerable female
he confronted or followed several women
I am sure that the defendant intended to
sexually assault a woman violently using
such Force as required to achieve
submission and to frighten her although
I do not sentence on the basis that this
was a premeditated murder I'm also
satisfied that he was quite prepared to
kill if necessary as it turned out he
decided it was
secondly although he has no previous
convictions for sexual offenses or
crimes of serious violence the
prosecution relies on records of his
previous aggressive behavior as an
aggravating feature
the evidence is of four specific
incidents since 2009 and a large number
of incidents of aggression in prison
I ignore the earliest incident provided
by the prosecution
but in 2010 his partner alleged domestic
violence she told the police that he had
assaulted her pushed her down the steps
pulled her hair and strangled her
she bore visible injuries he was
arrested and he gave an account to the
police largely in line with what she had
said but he excused himself
because she had been quotes going on
and as a result he lost his temper
between May 2018 and June 2019 he abused
another woman with whom he was in a
relationship soon after it began
he would slap her punch her beat her
kick her in the ribs and drag her along
the road
in February 2020 while in prison he
threatened to kill a prison officer who
had spoken to him after he'd damaged his
cell
he said he would cut off his head
and open him up
this sort of threatening attitude and
behavior is his default presentation
intelligence reports disclosed to the
defense demonstrate that on the 20th of
December 2015 whilst located in the
segregation unit of a prison he made
threats to carry out very serious harm
to a prison officer who was female
they also include a report that in March
2017 he became abusive and aggressive
when asked to remove photographs from
his cell wall by another female officer
to whom the defendant also made threats
of really serious bodily harm including
stabbing he said I've stabbed govs
before check my file and watch what I do
to you
his record of adjudications in custody
shows that he had 223 adjudications
between August 2010 and June 2022
165 of which resulted in charges
139 resulted in verdicts and 169
resulted in sanctions
among them are numerous adjudications
for committing assault and for using
threatening abusive or insulting words
or behavior
the police intelligence unit incidents
for a prisoner report records 102
incidents
for Jordan McSweeney between August 2012
and April 2022
amongst these incidents are serious
assaults on other inmates improvised
weapons being found in Jordan
mcsweeney's possession and general
disobedience
I remind myself that it is only that
which I can be sure of to the criminal
standard of proof that can be relevant
to the decision I must make on a minimum
term I am sure to that standard that the
defendant is a pugnacious and deeply
violent man with a propensity to
violence in my judgment this material is
also relevant to the extent that it
demonstrates that his behavior on the
night of the 26th of June 2022 was not
an aberration it was a steep and sudden
escalation of violence which had
simmered in his life for many years
thirdly I have to determine whether this
is a case in which I am sure that the
degree to which miscellina suffered
mentally or physically before her death
is an aggravating feature
it is argued that she is likelihood to
have been unconscious very early on and
during much of the attack
that she remained unconscious is
speculation and there is evidence
contrary to that suggestion including
the need as he saw it for the defendant
to return to the victim twice after
initially leaving her
she survived eight hours after the
attack
I'm sure she will have suffered
inordinately and this is an aggravating
feature
fourthly I have no doubt Jordan
McSweeney intended to kill Zara Alina
the nature of his attack stomping on her
head and the fact that he returned twice
drives me to the conclusion that this
was a determined intention to kill
finally is there any degree to which
culpability for this murder is lowered
because of a mental disorder or
disability
Mr Carter Stevenson submits that I
should have regard to the defendant
statement at the police station that he
has attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder and personality disorder
as I observed to counsel the court has
no psychiatric report from any expert
who examined the defendant
I have considered the report of the
psychologist Dr Black very carefully
I bear in mind all the mental ill health
identified therein which Council has
summarized as making the defendant
someone who struggles in the community
and has a real difficulty in making and
maintaining a healthy social life and
relationships
despite the Brokenness the defendant has
experienced I do not consider that there
is any cogent material upon which I can
conclude that the mental health issues
which he undoubtedly has or the
anti-social conditioning from his
upbringing are capable of reducing his
culpability to any material extent
I sentence him on the basis that his
mental faculties were such that he Bears
full responsibility for his actions
the presence of the following
aggravating features is agreed the
location and timing of the offense in
public in the early hours of the morning
witnessed partly by members of the
public and the attempts made to dispose
of or conceal evidence such as the
blood-stained clothing and shoes
two other factors which I consider to be
important require attention firstly I'm
sure that the taking of miscellina's
mobile phone was a deliberate attempt to
prevent her calling for help or giving a
description of what had happened to her
before she died
and secondly he had shortly before being
released from the sorry he had shortly
before been released from the
defendant's most recent sentence
the revocation of his license on the
24th of June was placed on the police
national computer on the 25th of June in
my judgment he committed this offense in
the expectation that he was likely to be
returned to custody soon in any event
apart from the guilty pleas I find no
mitigation he has never expressed any
remorse or demonstrated empathy for the
outcome of his behavior in evidence
he cried at the police station but this
was after his arrest for murder and rape
and it was not accompanied by an
expression of Sorrow for the impact on
anyone else
his license has been revoked and he has
been serving the remainder of his
previous sentence while on remand so
there are no days to be counted against
the sentence I passed today
I have taken care to avoid double
counting the sexual assault is a
category 1A offense because the
defendant used violence and threats and
abducted the victim from the street
there was a significant degree of
premeditation because he wandered around
the area until he found the ideal
circumstances in which to commit the
offense
this was a particularly violent sexual
assault committed at night in a public
place on a woman out alone
the defendant removed miscellina's
knickers and caused injuries to her
genitalia as well as the injuries that
led to her death
the sentence for that offense of sexual
assault had I been dealing with it alone
would have been six years imprisonment
taking into account his history of
offending had there not been a guilty
plea I would allow one-third discount
for The Plea I take the few that this
offense has already incorporated into
the minimum term for murder because I
have taken the highest starting point of
30 years and I reflect the aggravating
features of it in the minimum term for
the murder
having been arrested on the 27th of June
the defendant was charged with murder
and rape on the 29th of June
on reception in prison he indicated that
he could not comprehend that he had done
what he had done
he appeared for a preliminary hearing on
the 1st of July 2022 and his ptph was
set for the 30th of September 2022.
prior to the listing the solicitors
acting for the defendant wrote to the
court to inform them that they had not
received an expert report commissioned
from a psychiatrist because the
defendant not seen him
furthermore
owing to the industrial action being
taken by the defense bar his instructed
Advocate would not be present
accordingly I adjourn the hearing to the
19th of October and an extension was
given for service of the defense
statement
the defendant failed without a
reasonable excuse to attend two
appointments with the psychologist on
the 21st of September and the 3rd of
October
his solicitors wrote to the court again
to request a further adjournment
when the case came before the court for
ptph on the 19th of October the
defendant refused to attend and it
became apparent that he had not attended
a conference that had been arranged with
his solicitors
the defense were directed to secure the
services of a psychologist who could
provide a report as soon as possible and
the ptph was adjourned to the 24th of
October
on that date the solicitors still did
not have a report and the ptph was
adjourned once again to the 11th of
November
in the report of Dr Black which is dated
the 26th of October and which was I'm
sure in the hands of the defense soon
after that date the defendant suggests
that he did not remember what had
happened and he could not believe what
he was seeing when shown the CCTV an
interview in fact the police interviews
after arrest the defendant affected a
board and disinterested facade
the defendant was not produced at the
next hearing because he tested positive
for coved the ptph was put back to the
16th of November
despite a direction that he attend in
person the defendant refused to come to
court on the 16th of November and a
video link had to be arranged
the defense took instructions from the
defendant and approached the prosecution
about potential pleas and this was
indicated to the court the ptph was
adjourned to the 19th of November and on
that occasion the defendant pleaded
guilty to the preferred two-count
indictment murder and sexual assault
I accept that the prosecutor that the
defense solicitors commissioned expert
reports to ensure there was no
psychiatric defense to the charge of
murder and to ensure Fitness to plead
and to be tried these were responsible
steps in a case of such gravity
I also accept that because of the action
taken by criminal barristers the
defendant was not able to receive advice
from Junior barristers or King's Council
until October this year
I reject the suggestion from the defense
that because he was heard on a prison
phone telling his mother that he was
banged to rights he should be taken to
have indicated at a very very early
stage that he would accept
responsibility for the killing he never
indicated this to the court until the
16th of November and at stages his
non-engagement frustrated the work being
done on his behalf
in addition as Mr Carter Stevenson
accepted in his written submission on
sentence
he caused some additional delay through
taking a belligerent attitude when
required to come to court including
telling the jailers on one occasion that
there was no point in attending a
hearing at which he was required
overall my conclusion is
that the defendant is entitled to less
than the maximum discount on the murder
count and I would allow one-eighth
although given the length of the term I
will impose the maximum discount allowed
can be five years
considering all these features
after a trial the minimum term would
have been 43 years
I allow five years as I have said for
the plea of guilty indicated by Council
on the 16th of November a few weeks
before trial
a sentence of four years concurrent is
imposed for sexual assault
the sentence for the brutal sexually
motivated murder of Zara Alina is
imprisonment for Life the defendant will
serve 38 years as the minimum term
the court would like to thank Council
and also to commend Mr and Mrs Condor
Georgina Woolard and Maria Bergen